trump was giving the covet press
briefings daily
yep he saw his highest approval rating
in aggregate for his entire presidency
they immediately said he's lying shut
down the events and they cut away and
stopped covering them
yep that was smart on their part they
have done some things that have
benefited them
smart do you hear that america the media
doesn't want you to see it and they call
it
smart just well that was there i'm just
pointing that well i'm calling it smart
in terms of their strengths for them
right and but you're right that was
their strategy yeah cut
cut the people off from the president of
the united states well look because they
don't want him to act
they don't want him to actually hear
what the president has to say
because news flash he's actually a good
president when people hear trump
he does better right recently trump's
approval rating has been going up
and the pollsters attribute this to his
re
him reviving press briefings on kovid
yep because people
when they hear what he has to say all of
a sudden they start liking the guy
and it's because the media lies all the
time trump is far from perfect but
man does the lead the media lie about
everything
yep so listen the point i was making is
there
there's a few things the left has done
that has benefited them the left the
media and the democrats
but for the most part it's like they're
they're they're five steps behind
trump so something happens 40 chess
yeah it's it's you know what i think i
don't think trump is playing 4d chess
i think trump is playing chess i think
the democrats are playing checkers
trump's been preparing for his
presidency
since the 80s i know it did
he's been prepping for this he knows
what he's doing
he was friends with all the democrats he
knew what they were what how they played
the game
he was part of their he was in the
circles
he he was aware and now he's he went
against them
and now that they're like whoa i mean
you see what happened in 2016
and how they've ramped up their
anti-trump rhetoric
it's like dude he knows what he's doing
and he's smart
he's gonna he's gonna win this this fall
well that's good news for the media yeah
that's great news for the media let's
talk about take a look take a look at
this article everybody
from digiday there's no antagonist news
outlets
mull the possible end of their editorial
and business side trump
bonanza and i want you all to laugh at
the fear in their hearts of what would
it mean
what it would mean if trump would lose
but then i want you to throw up in your
mouth a little bit when you realize
they're cheering for trump winning
yep they want him to win i've talked
about this with a couple other people in
the past
that cnn secretly wants trump to win of
course they do
yeah because he's their whole existence
i tell you what man
there's something called what what do i
call the cnn challenge
oh what's that it's where you put on fox
news at a random time during the day
and then see what they're talking about
and then change the channel to cnn
and they'll be talking about trump i
call it that yeah so i've posted this if
you check out my instagram
instagram.comcast i posted two videos
where it's like i turn on fox and
they're like we've got a major serious
weather
storm front coming up to the gulf it's
going to be reaching these states you
know make sure
you buy supplies and i'm like all right
severe weather you know possible risk to
the american people
switch to cnn it's a panel where like
now donald trump may be the worst
president but
so then a few days later i'm like
flipping through i turn on fox news and
it's like riots have erupted in iran
could challenge the government
and i'm like wow international affair
that put on cnn now donald trump is he
the worst president i certainly think
he's the worst president
that's the game they play yeah so so
they know what it means
they know what it means if trump loses
and that's it's a really interesting
thing because
a lot of the progressives have been
complaining about this okay if you if
you follow the progressive circles
they complain about how it's all trump
all the time and how that helps trump
so remember that woman we just had that
story of that msnbc reporter
who resigned okay one of the complaints
she had
was that even when it's not about trump
it's about biden they somehow try and
make it trump
the media i wouldn't say that they're
trying to make trump win
but i will say they love the opportunity
and what ends up happening is they
inadvertently help him by giving him
endless free press and you know what's
interesting is when
when i see a story and the media lies
my you know like they'll put out a story
where it's like you know donald trump
does bad thing when i see that my
reaction isn't oh no donald trump did a
bad thing it's
i am sick and tired of the lies yep and
it makes me
really want to just slam that trump
button in spite
of the deception and and and the and
just the
the duplicitousness i do not like being
taken advantage of
and i really really don't like when
people try to manipulate me well these
news medias are are acting like they
the internet doesn't exist they're
acting as if people
can't circumvent their news media
like we can't just go fact check
ourselves and
watch his press briefings live
while it's actually going on on youtube
on whatever there's countless different
places you can watch it
and that's why they're trying to shut us
down that's true that's why
they ban people who say things like
learn to code a simple joke they're like
an opportunity to ban and purge people
you're gone
they don't want you to have that ability
they suspend the president's own tweets
yep
and they make up the bs copyright claims
on satire
and they they they call them fake news
they label accurate
uh tweets false information like what
happened to you yesterday yeah
yep they play dirty games where trump
will say something and they'll take it
out of context on purpose to claim it's
false yeah like the famous acid wash
fact check so so just quickly because
you got to know this if you don't
many of you probably do trump claimed
hillary clinton acid washed her server
we all know what he means we're saying
rational people he's using it's it's a
figure of speech
and nbc news said false hillary clinton
did not use a corrosive chemical on her
computer
well nobody thought that are you nuts
yeah you take it literally but
what he meant was that she purged the
hard drives which she deleted a bunch of
files
yeah and she totally did this is the you
were mentioning the media doesn't
realize that we can go around them yeah
exactly
i think some of them do but they know
many people won't
because they're used to it well and and
a lot of people are working
they they don't have that much time
there's like the time they do have
they're making food
you know like oh let me just see what's
on the news and i'll i'm doing something
i'm kind of not really paying attention
but i'm getting the information
you know or at the airport you know cnn
is in every airport so they're spreading
they're paying millions of dollars for
that right to spread their message
everywhere
which which is lies hillary clinton was
campaigning
in 2016 and she was at some southern
event and she talked with a southern
drawl okay and everybody was like
uh does she not know what the internet
is
right yes guess what back in the day
when the politicians would travel around
the country they'd jump to chicago and
be like
how's it going everybody my name's uh
tim i'm here from chicago and i'm
running for president and pretty good
pretty good chicago yeah people would be
like hey doc's just like me this guy
yeah
i'm gonna vote for this guy my name is
bob i make garage doors and uh you know
grass door openers and this guy
represents me here in chicago and i
watch the bears then
they go to brooklyn and they talk with a
brooklyn accent yeah they go to the
south they talk with a southern accent
oh you would do so well man
exactly you would so so here we have
look there really is this mentality
among these establishment types
especially someone like joe biden
does he not know that we watch him on
camera say words he might not
he doesn't yeah he might actually not he
might just
my favorite was when he was he was like
uh and i'm uh i'm
i'm what do i say what do i say
like come on he's like trying to cue
cards yeah like what do i say come on
give me something to say it's like did
you see do you see the one where
he just breaks down in the interview and
then and then his staffer turns the
interview off and says that's all the
time we haven't just shut it off
hilarious
that's scary man i don't know there's
there's this like little bit
of piece of me that it's like is he
faking it
is he really that demented he's gonna
want us
he's gonna walk us man he's gonna come
out there and just be like well i'm
actually joe biden and i'm ready to well
donald trump you got to paint the
picture better all right
they're going to wheel him out in a
wheelchair and he's going to have a
blanket on his lap
and then he's going to struggle to stand
up and he's going to be shaking and then
he's going to fall straight forward and
everyone's gonna gasp
then he's gonna do a perfect somersault
jump right up and go hey and he's gonna
mosey on over and he's gonna do a little
shuffle dance willy wonka willy wonka no
i don't really don't believe it
i don't know so they they're so right
now you know trump is saying
biden wants to defund the police that's
technically true
joe biden was asked if he would be in
favor of redirecting funds and he said
yes absolutely
it's like these people don't know
they're on camera even kamala harris has
been
she she hasn't been on record on
actually saying defund the police
but she was applauding the la mayor for
right for defunding the police these
people have no politics
no i'll tell you i'll tell you what i
see all right there's there's always
room to criticize trump
but when i see trump he's like here's
the things i want to do
and i'm like i believe he wants to do
those things trump says
i'm going to build a big beautiful wall
from cedar shining sea and the best he
can do is ballard fencing
but he wanted border security i can see
i can understand his general idea
he really did want massive thick walls
and it's
it's to help stop human trafficking a
lot of this is a big issue
but he's fighting it dude the wall issue
is a perfect example of trump's mistakes
and his intention okay trump wanted
border security
to him he said big beautiful wall 30
feet high from sea to shining sea
ice and cbp came to him and said we need
to be able to see through it
because there might be people on the
other side and we need to know where
they're going
okay and it was like oh that's why
bollard fencing makes more sense
yeah you do a big wall you won't know
where they're going
so then for budgeting reasons and for
you know strategy
and tactics they decide to do the
fencing instead but what trump was
really telling the american people was
i want to guarantee the security of this
nation and its southern border
yeah if you if you think about what he
says in his intention
you believe him and then he did it yeah
there's a lot of things he didn't get
done he want to make mexico pay for it
you can argue about you know tax
incentives and trade-offs and
free trade whatever the point is he
didn't get everything he wanted
because he comes from a business
background and this is what i see
he comes from a world where when you're
running a business you can snap your
fingers and tell your
staffers and your commanders here's what
i need done go do it he enters
government
and now there's red tape everywhere and
he's trying to like move through it and
it's difficult
but you can you can see his intent is
legitimate but even as a businessman
even in that that uh field that he was
in
he made moves where a lot of other
people would be sitting there going
how do we make this happen when he was
actually out there going
i'm gonna make this happen and then
doing it and making it happen so him
building the wall like what you said you
know he wanted to build it
for security of our nation
but then you you followed it up by on
the southern border you didn't even need
to say that because
that's literally what people want they
want security in our nation absolutely
and and joe biden is not that
trump is is he said it that's what his
plan is he's proven time and time again
throughout his entire career
when he says something he follows
through with it trump
the reason i bring that up is that when
trump says he wants to do something
i legitimately believe he means it
agreed he's like we're gonna bring back
jobs gonna be better than ever the tpp
was awful nafta was a terrible trade
deal first thing he does he nukes tpp
yep he hurts renegotiating
nafta and and here's what i see whether
you disagree with him or not that's fine
but you look at what trump is doing and
i'm like he means what he says
you look at joe biden he'll say whatever
you tell him to say yeah
what are you going to vote for whatever
his handlers tell him to say
this i look at joe biden and i'm like i
have no idea what he wants to do other
than sniff kids
like no i'm not or have him sit on his
lap or touch his legs
yeah whatever he says about it is creepy
listen but but i really do mean this
what does joe biden want to do for this
country okay is he for
medicare for all is he opposed to it i
don't know he's flip-flopped and he's
like tried to pander to the far left and
his public option
he says moratorium on deportations now
he's saying buy america build back
better he's trying to
emulate trump he's tough on china then
he says china they're good people and
you can't you can't blame them for this
which is it he put out an ad where he
was like trump is soft on china
and i was like are you insane he really
did that yep and then you got pelosi
coming out going well
china wants joe biden to be president
yeah
you're acting like a crazy old person
the crazy ones not all but they're crazy
but the pelosi
is one of those crazy old people with
the claw hands
i'll put it this way this is the way it
is
if you if you uh uh captured
you know it's a better word if you
mandated for the debate
between trump and biden and kamala
and they were administered with a truth
serum do you know what trump would end
up saying the exact same
exact same stuff he'd be insulting
people he'd be like no listen
morons they have no idea what they're
talking about and and people would be
like
he's not any different excuse me excuse
me i'm correct but that's what he's
saying
excuse me wrong no terrible deal and
people in the audience would be like
but we gave him the truth serum why why
not
yes exactly he'd be saying that too yep
you give the truth serum to joe biden
kamala harris
and joe biden would be like look my
number one priority on day one is to
assume power
and have power and be in control benefit
my family and get them lucrative jobs in
four countries
and make sure they can live well and i
have no interest at all on the american
people
and these people just told me to say
that and now
i i'm being told i shouldn't be saying
anything anymore
like uh i'll go back to your basement
would be like listen
you know i'm here because i want power
over other people
and i want them to go to prison because
it's funny to me and i probably make
money because i've made deals with them
that's all they care about man i don't
know if that's true by the way
i just kind of this is why they're out
there this is why i can't stand the
establishment
and that includes republicans they
represent to me people who just want the
keys to the castle
that's all they've ever wanted and you
know what i i blame myself a little bit
i think i blame a lot of americans a lot
of people who don't vote
but i really do blame the people who
keep voting back and forth
there there's actually it's an
interesting conundrum
where i didn't vote in the past
following obama
because i'm like what's the point i'm
gonna what mitt romney
no barack obama sorry you know fool me
once
and then we get in 2016 i see trump and
i see hillary and i'm like nah i'm just
not interested
we're at a point now where we're seeing
how bad it really gets
trump has really improved what is this
look on your face what is this what is
this
he's got he's got a smile on his face
god just i have a feeling i know where
you're going with this
when was the last time trump said
something inappropriate about another
person
i don't know he's been rather he's been
rather presidential
as of late he has been he's been pretty
good about this
he hasn't said anything super insulting
in fact someone was just saying that
when he contains it his approval rating
goes
really weird right and i was thinking
about it he won the presidency
being that obnoxious person anyway so
if his approval rating has just gone up
from there i'm voting for him
i didn't vote for him last time it was
it was hillary but i i didn't want to i
was
i didn't want to interrupt you my smile
i couldn't i couldn't hold it back
but you were go go don't don't don't
stop
what in 2016 i was initially on the
bernie sanders
i want to call it a train um it was a
trump train and the bernie sanders
volkswagen or something and uh i was
because
i thought bernie was was more like trump
okay he actually was
but bernie sold out in two seconds oh
yeah as soon as given the opportunity to
be a millionaire he was like
uh do you vote for the establishment the
and ignore the millionaires
if they're okay now as soon as he made
all that money you look at what he's
saying now actually i think i might have
i don't know if i have an article about
it
but there was uh oh i actually do check
this out from forbes bernie sanders
congratulations to kamala harris who
will make history as our next vice
president
she understands what it takes to stand
up for working people fight for health
care for all
and take down the most corrupt
administration in history let's get to
work and win
let me let me give you a pseudo applause
bernie because bernie sanders
one of his former staffers brianna joy
gray says we are in the midst of the
largest protest movement in american
history
the subject of which is excessive
policing and the democratic party chose
a top
cop and the author of the joe biden
crime bill to save us from trump
the contempt for the base is wow
yeah that's crazy but i'm highlighting
this talk about bernie sanders in 2016
bernie said tpp terrible nafta awful
deal
open borders koch brothers proposal we
don't want any of that and i'm listening
to him and i'm like you're here brother
i hear you bernie and i'm like here's a
guy who's been in office for for decades
who stood up for these issues time and
time again here he is now
standing up for the working people
opposing the the wealthy
you know money in politics all these bad
things and i was like i'm here for it
even though
i really disagree with a lot of his far
tax far-left policies
there was enough there i liked and i i
talked i actually talked to a lot of
people
throughout the 2016 campaign when bernie
finally dropped out
and it was obvious it was going to be
hillary i met these guys in anaheim who
told me it was it was an older dude and
two younger guys and they got ended up
getting beaten up by the far left
chased out and spit on and hit they told
me that they were bernie sanders
supporters
who switched for trump because trump was
the only
other guy who was offering up anything
to the working class
and all these other people who are now
supporting hillary clinton they they
don't even know what they're talking
about
right they end up getting attacked of
course so yeah so we end up seeing
bernie sanders
flipping and now i'm kind of like okay
so i stood out and i was like whatever
man what a ridiculous election i don't
care fool me once i'm not playing these
games
now we're at a point where trump really
has chilled out
and that's a fact that you like the
thing like there's a lot he was doing
and i explained this back in the day
that really put off
moderate liberal types inappropriate
behavior things that are funny but not
the president should be doing
the last two press conferences trump had
super calm
thank you for your question yes
collected yeah i think he was waiting
until we got closer to the vp
announcement and now he's going to be
more stoic more rational more chilled
out at least that's what i'm seeing now
so i was thinking about everything we're
seeing with the far left with the riots
what trump's actions have been how the
media has lied
and now i'm thinking you know what i've
said this several times the far left
would be better served
by another four years of trump to
finally
end the crony establishment boom that's
it keep them out
then in four years the far left can step
up with a better candidate and get rid
of the pelosis the schumers the bidens
the kamalas
don't let them win i don't think they're
going to win at this point
but that's what i see and i talked about
i've been talking about for a while
listen man
you know trump is the bull rampaging
through the ivory tower and the
establishment is being forced out and
they're
desperately trying to hold on you give
trump four more years
you might not like him personally or his
policies the far left has a better
chance
of getting their policies enacted with
trump as the president
than as the democrats retaining
establishment control and kicking all
populists out
not not that i want them to win on a lot
of things i actually lean left on many
issues but they're way too far left for
my tastes
but i'll tell you this if the
establishment wins the far left
will will be pushed out and so will the
populist right
all populists will just be crushed
they'll start they will immediately
seize the reigns
social media will silence and ban
everybody anti-war anybody who's
populist they're
already trying to do it yep so that's
why i'm sitting here now
well that's just this is one of the
reasons honestly think about uh
you know all the presidents
every president you know they they come
into office they
have a really good approval rating and
they tend to go down over time
yeah trump's been it was the opposite it
went down and started
climbing he came in low and it's just
been climbing
and climbing technically oh well all
right i'm
generalizing it he got elected and saw a
big spike and then it just dropped off
right but it's slowly been going up but
then you think about why
you think about russiagate you think he
he called it treason today on his press
briefing
obama he called biden my name obama
by name all these other people that were
part of it comey
he was like this it's treason what they
did they spied on me they used
they used uh fisa to like phony fisa bs
yeah exactly
that was bad man and his approval rating
is just going up and up and up
maybe dude he's gonna but i don't make
some moves i don't i don't i don't trust
the polls i don't trust the polls either
i saw meme
there was like this this is a meme post
on facebook and it said
my neighbor across the street used to
fly a trump flag one day i noticed that
the flag was gone
and i was out mowing the lawn and he
came over and started we started talking
and he's like i mentioned this the
bumper sticker on my car for a
progressive candidate
and he asked me about about her and i
told her and then i asked him why did
you take your trump flag down
and he said you know it's because my
grandson came to me and asked me why i
supported a racist
sexist bigot and i had no answer and i
realized
you know if you lose the respect of your
grandson then what have you got and i
was like explain to your grandson that
he's not any of those things
no my response to that is yes and then
everyone standing around started
clapping
it didn't happen that didn't happen of
course not i've i've i
i was talking there's there's a couple i
don't i want to drag drag some people
into this but there are some some
moderately high profile individuals
who host a show and i was talking to
them back in like 2017
they said from europe all the news they
saw said hillary hillary hillary
that's it then they came and flew back
to the u.s and landed
and saw nothing but trump signs and
immediately
said trump's going to win and people
laughed at them they're like you're nuts
and they were like you've not been on
the ground in these towns you've not
driven around
tell me where you've seen the hillary
sign yeah and right now are there biden
signs
so i get it man people are saying
they're going to vote against trump
and that's what they're really doing i
wonder
how many how many people are going to
vote how many people will vote
just simply because they hate trump
people are having trump rallies on their
own
there's boat rallies happening across
this nation right now what was that
photo
i'm reading into it i got you so i'm one
of them i mean
all right so there's this one picture of
just
massive trump they got like 15 trump
flags
all the way up the whole sales and
there's this picture of
all these different uh you know boats
just rocking the trump flag
and there's this one guy in a kayak
holding up a handwritten
biden 2020 sign and then uh you know
they're trying to say now
what it proves that trump is it's all
the rich people who can afford boats
and it's like dude have these people
ever financed a boat like how much do
you think it costs
to finance a boat right it's not that
much no not docking fees and stuff but
these are middle-class people yeah
they got a boat it's a couple hundred
bucks plus docking fees and it's all
over the place yeah there's i've seen
boating
in florida in minnesota in iowa
man where else have i seen it delaware
river right right river right in
the area yeah exactly that was crazy
because everywhere man
they were big boat parades trump 2020.
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you